comment va la gauche Éric coqurel vous
personnellement vous êtes plutôt en
forme vous avez été réélu à la tête de
la très puissante commission des
finances à l'Assemblée mais le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que rien n'est
réglé au sein des des fractures
profondes qui divisent la Nupe on voit
ça avec Marco pommier on en parle juste
après si on vous invite Eric cocrel
c'est parce que vous rempilez à la tête
de la stratégie commission des finances
de l'Assemblée merci beaucoup un temps
sur
après avoir jugé recevable la
proposition de loi du groupe lot pour
abroger la réforme des retraites vous
vous êtes finalement bel et bien imposé
comme président de la commission des f
bah écoutez il est il me paraît juste
équilibré et juste je dois dire que
depuis le début de ce mandat il a montré
un grand respect des oppositions un
député insoumis à la tête de la
commission des finances du jamais vu
pour un trotskiste engagé à la Ligue
révolutionnaire pendant 15 ans vous
l'adolescent anarch
dans la rue des 14 ans vieux compagnon
de route de Jean-Luc Mélanchon fidèle
parmi les fidèles et pourtant écarté de
la direction de la France insoumise
qu'importe vous ne vous éloignez pas du
rivage insoumis alors que vous aimez
prendre le large éic coqurel navigateur
amateur passionné de voile organisateur
du premier vent des globes en 1989 je
suisti une génération post 68 pas 68
mais post 68
dans lequel on on rêvait soit de
transformer le monde soit pour certains
si on y arrivait pas d'en faire le tour
aujourd'hui Éric coqurel vous naviguez
en nos troubles le navire amiral nupess
semble au bord du naufrage
personnellement je ne fais pas la nupess
parce que j'aime les autres je ne les
aime pas alors pour le bien de la
coalition faut-il se débarrasser du
passager Roussell ou du capitaine
Mélenchon et dans un tel climat les
élections européennes ne sont-elles pas
l'iceberg du Titanic nupes
pour l'instant c'est chacun son cap
chacun sa liste vous souhaitez pourtant
l'Union chez les insoumis ce soir notre
question va de soi ériic coocrel comment
maintenir la coalition à flot réponse
Éric cocrel bah peutêre vous y croyez
oui oui j'y crois oui j'y crois pour une
bonne raison je vais vous dire une chose
c'est que moi je considère qu'on a une
politique toujours plus réactionnaire à
la tête de l'État j'hésite même pas à
dire que sur certains aspects il y a une
extrême
droitisation du gouvernement sur bien
des aspects
autoritarisme violence
policière la façon de discriminer et
cetera autoritarisme c'est fort hein
comm non non non je je l'assume voyez il
y a des dérives autoritaires je trouve
quand vous avez un ministre de
l'Intérieur qui en pleine été donne
raison à des policiers qui réclament le
fait que contre la justice de ne pas
pouvoir être mis en en en détention
provisoire alors que la justice l'a
décidé je pense que c'est des choses qui
m'inquièent donc je vous dis je on conna
les
inquiétudes et que ce soit avec le RN ou
que ce soit avec une droite qui
s'extrême droitise je
crain donc je vous explique à partir du
moment où il y a un danger comme ça le
pays en général et bien il faut le
rassemblement de toute la gauche sur un
programme de rure qui assiste bienUt et
pour l'instant peut-être mais ce que je
je vous fais remarquer c'est que la
dernière élection principale les
présidentielle législative ont donné une
majorité justement à cette gauche qui
pour la première fois est une gauche
depuis longtemps en tout cas est une
gauche qui s'incarne sur un programme de
rupture qui est le seul à même de battre
l'extrême libéralisme et l'extrême
droite pour cette raison je pense que
nous resterons ensemble voilà je pense
que nous resterons ensemble quoi à la
présidentielle oui je pense que nous
mais pas aux différentes élections
intermédiaire on le voit c'est chacun
dans son coin aux européennes c'est
probablement la même chose pour les
municipales leain de
scrutinise pas attendez le pire n'est
jamais certain comment en tout cas sur
les européennes c'est fin a priori c'est
fini vous abandonnez mais il reste
quelques mois et moi je pense qu'il faut
continuer à dire que une liste
rassemblée de laanupess serait largement
préférable pour nous mettre en rapport
de force justement par rapport au qui pe
nous
arverous la rupture les municipales vous
vous dites ça j'en sais rien et de cette
manière cette manière en tout cas je
suis pour essayer de conserver un espoir
à la nupess à partir du moment et
j'insiste là-dessus parce que l'UNIP
c'est pas juste l' de la gauche la nupes
c'est j'allais dire une pointe avancée
de l'Union Populaire que nous voulons
qui est sur un programme de rupture et
je pense que par ce que nous faisons
vous m'interrogz à l'Assemblée je
regarde moi j'essaie de regarder ce qui
marche nous avons fait une motion de
censure ensemble la semaine derère
préparons un contrebudget ensemble avec
l'anupes et donc là où l'anupes s'est
créé c'estàdire les députés et bien ça
continue à fonctionner je en sorte que
ça soit le cas faabien
Rousel on voudrait comprendre c'est lui
qui par ou c'est vous qui lui montrez la
porte il y a il y a une forme de rupture
là on est on a atteint un degré de
violence verbale maximal peut-être
peut-être mais on a quand même un
problème avec Fabien Roussel alors le
tout c'est de ça devienne pas un
problème avec le Parti communiste et de
dire à nos camarades communistes bah il
faut à un moment donné que c'est quoi
votre problème précisément parce qu'il a
dit que Jean-Luc méinchon ferait pas
gagner en 202 c'est que depuis
maintenant plusieurs moisprèsce que dès
le lendemain de l'élection et on sait
qu'en réalité dans les négociations il
était pas le plus farouche partisan PES
il annonce la fin de la nuupes il
explique par exemple que quoi qu'il
arrive il se présentera notamment en
2027 ça a déjà causé l'échec de pour la
nuupes d'arriver au deuxè tour avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il le dit à l'avance
à chaque fois excusez-moi mais j'écoute
ce que dit Fabien Rous à chaque fois
qu'on est attaqué par exle Darmanin nous
attaque il a des mots dou pour Darmanin
on nous attaque sur tel ou tel billet il
se débrouille pour donner raison à
casenu qui sont les plus antinupess au
partiiste donc je dis pas dehors je dis
qu'à un moment donné
on peut pas avoir des mots comme ça qui
sans arrêt sont des mots défiance
vis-àvis de la nupes et penser que ça
n'a pas de réaction donc nous on pointe
le problème je pense qu'on a bien fait
poserilà sont pas d'accord dor dans Rous
je suis pas d'accord avec cette phraseam
d'accord non mais c'est pas un problème
de condam ou pas c'est pas c'est pas que
ce soit
sopia repris un propos d'un de vos
confrères
danielman et ce qui qui a fait une
analyse par rapport
je ne suis pas d'accord ave c je vais
vous dire pourquoi d'abord parce que
elle est beaucoup
trop dure par rapport à à Rousel et
deuxièmement en plus ce que ça fait
c'est que ça ressoude le Parti
communiste autour de lui qui se St
attaqué donc elle est contreproductive
mais je voudrais pas qu'on inverse la
question parce que c'est pas cette
phrase le problème elle est très
violente hein c'est je vous dis je ne
suis pas d'accord avec cette pH c'est
pas ça c'est pas ça ce que porte Manu
bonpard ce que porte Mathilde panos ce
que nous portons que par rapport à
laanup ce n'est pas notre notre
expression officielle l'expression
officielle c'est que nous av avons des
critiques politiques sur la politique
menée par Fabien Roussel aujourd'hui et
je dis une chose moi je souhaite que les
les communistes restent dans la nues à
l'Assemblée ils y sont de manière totale
marche très bien a que Nicolas su à la
commission des finances mais pour ça il
faut arrêter j'allais dire de tirer sans
arrêt contre son
campit il y en a d'autres au sein même
des insoumis qui s'interrogent on va les
voir otin Ruffin garidau Corbière on
sait qu'ils se réunissent entre
régulièrement c'est un secret de
polyinel vousz les groupes la réunion du
groupe des des insoumis ici même à à
l'Assemblée tout le monde se réunit vous
savez ils ont raison de s'interroger sur
la candidature Mélenchon comment vous
regardez leur démarche j'ai pas entendu
excusez-moi mais là vous vous vous
personnalisez la question moi moi par
exemple sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon je l'ai
dit moi j'ai porté à certains moment
certaines critiques par rapport à à la
manière dont on organisé France
insoumise d'accord mais d'un autre côté
je vous dis aujourd'hui la candidature
de Jean-Luc c'est celle qui devrait
s'imposer celle qui est la plus efficace
et c'est celle que je soutiens donc moi
je n'ai pas entendu les camarades dont
vous parlez pointer leur question sur la
candidature de Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
pas ça qui est qui qui est question moi
je un peu quand même quand même non non
parce que la candidat jeanluc méenchon
aujourd'hui par exemple Jean-Luc dit
luime si aujourd'hui on verra en 2027 ce
qu' enancera et et ces décisions mais si
l'élection aujourd'hui se déroulait très
franchement une quasi totalité de France
insoumise estimerait que le bon candidat
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon et j'en fais
partie alors on sort un peu de la
tambouille de la nupes et des insoumis
la commission des finances que vous
présidez va commencer à examiner le
budget 2024 éducation justice intérieure
écologie pouvoir d'achat tous ces
budgets sont en forte hausse le
gouvernement ne fait pas le choix de
l'austérité il ne coupe pas brutalement
dans les dépenses est-ce que c'est un
choix que vous approuvez au moins alors
c'est c'est assez étonnant ce budget
parce
que c'est c'est un budget qui qui
finalement ne ne résout rien on va dire
c'est-à-dire que le gouvernement a une
un discours d'une politique libérale qui
est de dire il faut revenir à 2,7 % de
déficit en 2027 c'est ça vraiment
l'objectif essentiel c'est la dette et
cetera et cetera pas pour 2024 he mais
d'accord mais il l'annonce pour 2027 il
annonce que progressivement on va faire
des économies don 2025 où il annonce 12
milliards de dépenses en plus de de
moins de dépenses en terme de service
public donc voilà c'est son objectif
mais d'un autre côté bah il se retrouve
coincé par certaines évidences alors par
exemple c'est le pouvoir d'achat le fait
que vous avez 9 millions de frana de Pau
c'est le fait que la transition
écologique c'est quand même difficile de
la faire sans argent plus 7 milliards
pour la transition un chèque de 100 € et
puis arrive il est obligé d' mettre une
bombe sociale comme le logement avec le
fait que les gens n'arrivent plus à se
loger bien ou se logent trop cher et que
on a une crise sans précédent et je
pourrais vous décliner les problèmes en
terme de santé en terme d'éducation et
cetera donc sa difficulté c'est nous
dire il faut faire des économie faut pas
augmenter les impôts et il faut avoir un
déficit comme objectif bon il a bien du
du mal aller chercher ses économies vous
avez raison de le
constater pour autant justement parce
que ce budget en réalité ne résou rien
il ne répond pas à ce qui devrait être
au centre de la question aujourd'hui les
besoins des Français premier besoin des
Français la transition écologique
excusez-moi mais quand pisaniferie
annonce qu'il faut 37 milliards de
dépenses publiques pour amorcer 60
milliards d'ici 2027 pour simplement
respecter le le le fait de de de
d'arriver à 2050 avec zéro carbone et
bien et bien c'est pas avec 7 milliard
donc c'est pas suffisant je vais vous
dire comment vous fait c'est pareil sur
la question du logement la politique du
logement a baissé de 10 milliards en 10
ans donc moins de logements sociaux il
avec tous les problèmes qu' conna donc
moi je vous dis comment on les trouve
d'abord on arrête les les cadeaux
fiscaux aux plus riches que l'on a fait
depuis des
années on remet on arrête le flat taxe
parce que les revenus capital ont bien
profité des années Macron et c'est pas
juste un problème de justice fiscale
c'est que ça nous coûte juste par
exemple en 2022 50 milliards d'euros de
recettes en ça c'est une chose rich
j'imagine super profit bien évidemment
notamment par exemple vous savez c'est
75 riches plus riches français des
milliardaires qui aujourd'hui ont un
taux d'imposition sur le revenu
inférieur à 2 % et si on regarde le
leurs revenus globaux professionnels ils
sont même pas à 25 % d'imposition quand
la la moyenne pour les pour les 10 % les
plus j'ai 45 %ard
la semaine prochaine il nous reste une
petite poignée de seconde impossible
d'arrêter cette interview sans vous
poser la question sur sia chirou député
de Paris qui va être convoqué par la
justice en vue d'une possible mise en
examen selon nos confrères du monde pour
la gestion financière à la légalité
discutable de sa société de
communication médiascope qui est
intervenu dans plusieurs campagnes de la
France insoumise quelle est votre
réaction ma réaction c'est que j'entend
parler beaucoup de convocations depuis
maintenant des bois sur ces histoires de
2018 il y a pas que sopia Chikirou il y
a eu d'autres personnes euh on nous a
dit que il y a eu d'autres personnes qui
ont été convoquées dans les différents à
plusieurs reprises par rapport à à la
campagne de 2018 donc je rappelle que
les comptes avaient été certifiés et on
nous annonce sans arrêt beaucoup de
choses ces choses n'arrivent pas donc
quand elles arriveront on en discutera à
ce moment-là mais je vais vous dire une
chose moi déjà par rapport des
adversaires politiques j'ai pas euh je
commente vraiment très très peu non
seulement les décisions de justice avant
qu'ell soit prise mais alors en plus les
annonces de décisions de justice dont on
sa va le faire comptez pas sur moi pour
le faire avec des camarades j d'ériic
coqurel merci beaucoup